breaking news about the horrific murder
of a 20-year-old mom who was shot
point-blank while pushing her baby in a
stroller a law enforcement source
telling fox news the nypd is looking for
a person of interest the victim's
ex-boyfriend isaac argrow in what is
believed to be a domestic violence
murder the mother of the victim is
blaming the city for failing to protect
her daughter saying the family
called numerous times in the past for
her protection mayor eric adams rushing
to the scene last night and making guns
the focus earlier today he announced the
nation's first dna gun crimes unit watch
here
we know that there are too many guns on
our streets we're seeing the sickening
reality of the overproliferation of guns
and the obsession of using guns in our
country and as mayor and as a former
police officer i am dedicated to
stopping this madness greg this is
horrific once again we have to talk
about something that could have been
prevented well you know the thing is he
shows up at every
uh tragedy every murder scene and i get
it that's what you're supposed to do and
then he tells you that it's bad
right and that it's always this problem
but
it it says this to you it says you that
police usually do show up after the
crime is already committed which is why
you should when you catch a criminal you
should be keeping them behind bars
that's our first mistake and the second
point you need prevention and what's
prevention you need cops on the beat we
i don't i mean i remember living in the
city and seeing police on almost every
street you don't see that anymore if i
feel like you see more homeless drug
addicted zombies than cops by a long
shot and third and finally you gotta you
gotta listen to
the people when they say they're
threatened they knew who this guy was
she had been abused by this guy and yet
the system screwed her she's dead the
baby's got no mother no father
uh judge the
suspect was just uh identified and it
was given to fox news um but he's not
been arrested yet
well what's interesting about this and
besides the the tragedy and the horror
of it all uh you've got a
three-month-old baby he was you know in
a stroller on a summer night uh in what
was once the safest big city in the
united states uh
the mother is just shot dead execution
style it's a domestic violence homicide
it has all the earmarks of it the mother
had been beaten when she was pregnant
and six months pregnant okay and
domestic violence increases in intensity
and frequency as time goes on so anyone
who knows that woman knows that if he's
going to beat her six months pregnant
he's going to really take care of her
when she's not pregnant she called the
police
she went to court she was in a shelter
for battered women she did everything
she was supposed to do when the system
failed her the police failed her now i
don't know if she ever got to court if
she ever got an order of protection if
he was ever charged with a crime i don't
know but what i do know right now is
that in new york city it is open season
and we've got a mayor who as greg
rightly says shows up after the crime
and you know what i don't see the mayor
as a cop i see him as an ideologue
because he says he says there are more
guns in our cities it means more lives
lost first of all he's wrong about that
there are studies that say that states
with higher gun ownerships have fewer
gun murders we've also got the crime
prevention research center shows that
concealed handgun permit holders are
extremely law-abiding that's number one
number two can we hear from the governor
hokule i want to address that one let's
play that please
if you have the numbers to show that
it's the concealed carry permit holders
that are committing crimes i don't need
to have numbers
i don't need i don't have to have a data
point to point to to say that this is
going to all i know is i have a
responsibility to the people of this
state to have sensible gun safety laws
you have a responsibility to people of
new york state your responsibility then
is to go after carl heasty and andrea
stewart cousins and sign a law that puts
these criminals in jail when they commit
a crime stop with the ideological
nonsense the truth is when she says i
don't need numbers she doesn't know the
reality it is law-abiding citizens with
guns who are going to protect themselves
and not cops because you tied their
hands behind their backs jessica this is
causing a lot of people to decide to
leave liberal cities not just new york
but certainly we've seen that the
statistics of people leave in new york
it's stark and it wasn't just covid
no there was that data that came out
just this week about it um a big i think
it was an axios the report about it uh
this is something that i think started
maybe for a lot of people because of
code restrictions and now is continuing
or for people who stuck it out and are
looking around and saying oh my rent
just got hiked 25 to 35 percent
it doesn't feel safe here i don't know
if it's necessarily the best educational
system for my kids that's a big point
that people are making who are
considering you know whether they want
to do charter schools or pods or
whatever it might be
i grew up here i went to high school on
89th and park avenue
that's six blocks away from where this
happened um
it's it's truly frightening um it's not
just happening here it's it's happening
all over the country we had the woman
who was pushing her baby and the guy
drove into them and she managed to
i don't know how she pulled that off
that was incredible in l.a
we need
real policy positions that can become
actionable there are a lot of ideas
percolating around mayor adams has put
things out there we need to see how they
work in terms of the concealed carry
permits i agree with governor hochul in
so far as
that new yorkers and in new york city
for instance there's just a discomfort
with there being a lot of guns around
and she will continue to make people
no it's not good i i don't want to feel
uncomfortable but certainly saying i
don't need a number of you do
you do matter of numbers and we know
that the people who are committing these
crimes are criminals
if someone is going to burglarize a
house they're not going to a house where
there's a gun so if they know there's a
gun there they're not going in jesse
waters you'll not be comfortable
we get the post delivered to the
apartment every day and you this is on
the front page and i'm picking up and i
open it up and emma sees it across the
breakfast table
and she goes what does that say and she
looks at where this happened this is a
20-minute walk from our apartment and
she goes
jesse i want to move yep and that's just
her speaking from the heart because this
was i think last month three blocks from
my apartment they had the guy in all
black chasing the guy on the street
stabbing him so a couple more of these
and i'm moving to westchester upstate
new jersey god help me
and and because between covet and crime
people do not want to live in the city
anymore and forget if i'm wrong correct
me
if this guy's beating his wife or his
girlfriend and if he has a handgun
shouldn't that be red flagged away i
mean right
we don't have gloves in new york in new
york we don't have a red flag i thought
we had a red flag in new york i
guarantee you that gun is not legal okay
but either way if it was legal it should
have been taken from i don't like how
adams talks
why are you reading
why are you reading from notes you
should be speaking apart he sounds like
pierre the woman at the white house
press secretary you should be out there
pouring your heart out to people instead
of looking down and saying how much you
care and how bad guns are i don't trust
this guy
up next the liberal new york times
warning the democrats have stopped going
woke or face a beat down at the ballot
box
hi i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now